just days away from Sunday's runoff vote
into Kiev third place candidates CNN
Owen has thrown his support behind
president Richard erdogan both erdogan
and opposition leader Kamala kalichtaulu
headquartered iron's team his voters are
seen as key to securing Victory on
Sunday erdogan had finished just short
of 50 support in the first round while
Owen had secured just over five percent
of the vote well Russell sitter is live
for us from Ankara now and Russell just
how significant is this ahead of the
runoff
well as of the moment it is quite
difficult to predict which kind of
impact it will have this announcement
will have on the outcome of the second
round in the presidential election so
far it's not clear yet because we do not
know whether he will be able to move his
supporters in favor of president erdogan
in the runoff because as of now we still
do not know how his base is loyal to him
what's the extent of the emotional
connection between him and his
supporters because that has never been
tested yet however synonym is a young
far-right nationalist politician in
turkey and throughout of his election
campaign he has promised to his
supporters if he's elected he's going to
send back immediately send all of the
Syrian immigrants back to their
countries if voluntarily if not by force
so that has been the main argument the
main pillar of his election campaign so
as of now based on these ideas he has
also built an alliance with particularly
a party that's another far-right party
led by Amit USDA but now his part his
Alliance is quite fragmented so he today
announced that he's going to support
president erdogan but for now we still
do not know what is going to be impact
because it's not clear whether he's
going to be able to mobilize his Waters
his supporters in favor of President
erdogan however one thing is definitely
clear that in this second round the
nationalists are going to determine the
results okay thank you so much for that
update that is Russell Sarah for us in
Ankara
well joining us from Istanbul is Sarah
dimiralpa an associate professor of
ishik University I thank you very much
for joining us on this NewsHour I guess
first of all what's your reaction to
Owen going with erdogan was it widely
expected
hi thank you for having me
well um
it was relatively more expected since
yesterday when he suggested that
um he will
promote continuity and stability because
continuity and stability were
keywords of our Advanced campaign right
after a 20 years that's pretty much what
he could promise and just continuity
um rather than normalization of the
economy or Improvement of Rights and
Liberties are done focused on his
promise of stability So Yesterday many
people started to believe that
is probably going to support ad run when
he used do it continuity and today in
his speech today he also said that he
believed that both the executive branch
and the legislative branch being
dominated by the same party
um is a good thing
for stability and he justified his
decision based on this argument
so um
it was also
relatively expected because
most likely to lose in the second realm
she's facing an uphill yeah
um that's what I wanted to ask about you
you ask you about next I mean does this
basically mean that it's either one's
election to lose
can you repeat that sorry does that now
make erdogan the the overwhelming
favorite going into this runoff
right yeah yeah Ardon was already he had
a major advantage after the first round
we know that typically
um whichever leader takes the lead in
the first round is has a clear advantage
in the second round unless something
surprising happens that would affect
turnouts of both sides right and
um the gap between arduans and Calista
Roller's votes
um were not easy to
um close even if most all you know
non-supporters or most of them you know
supported kalista role because many of
kalista rules voters were not planning
to go vote in the second round because
they were highly demotivated
and already we knew that half of synonym
voters second choice was zardon we knew
that from the polls so
um probably sinan thought that him
supporting is not going to bring a win
for kalista roll so he's not going to be
the king maker if he supported
kalistarolu and he probably didn't want
to be on the losing side
um so yeah by and and I I expect some of
his voters
um not following his decision to uh
support arduan some of his supporters
are
include protest voters they are highly
secularists they have National
sentiments so in that respect they may
have similarities with the incumbent
side but they are secularists so they
keep their distance to ardawn and his
People's Alliance
of correspondent was was talking a
little bit about this uh a couple of
minutes ago basically saying that Owen
built his presidential campaign on
pledges of sending refugees uh back to
their countries aggressively what will
happen to them now if erdogan does get
reelected I mean is that is that a real
possibility here
well sending refugees back
May secure a tightening
Refugee policies and like limits feature
admission of refugees but sending
existing refugees back
I don't think I think it's a slim chance
um that's I don't think this is a high
possibility particularly
um Edwin just two days ago
um clearly said that he has no intention
of sending refugees back
so I don't see I don't expect Ardon to
take a step back there
okay we'll have to leave it there but
thank you so much for your time and your
Insight that is
an associate professor at ishic
University thank you